is coming from men with low self-esteem
eg we call them simps we call them all
kind of funny names now if you're in an
arena where women are
dominant and they're allowed to say and
do as they wish which we have right now
we have platforms social media etc
a lot of men will shy away from their
true self just to appease the women in
the arena because i agree as a man you
want women to attract to you it's a
natural thing it's a biological thing
you know what i mean so
a lot of guys don't have they don't know
how to talk to women i've experienced it
and i i've seen it but i think it's hard
for men because when you think about it
like they're they're told if they
approach a girl the wrong way they can
their girl can cry s a
yeah and so how are they going to be
confident when they're told many men
ain't [ __ ] from the time they're 12.
how did the other men do it how did the
confident men do it well because because
um we have a smaller and smaller
percentage of men screwing all the girls
so again women find 80 of men as
unattractive and they only swipe right
five percent of the time on dating apps
so the reason the dating markets kind of
f'd up right now is because four girls
that are fours five six and sevens are
sleeping with the eights nines and tens
and they think they're on that level and
they're not and they're rejecting the
guys that are on their level because a
guy is willing to sleep with anyone
right so but that doesn't mean that
doesn't that doesn't mean you're that
hot
that's the difference
to that as well you have to remember
that women are also breaking up the
homes so the men that would that would
traditionally raise other men to become
men are no longer there because
as we know about 80 to 90 of women did
leave or divorce their husband for
the primary reason being financial
reasons
and the second being infidelity but
infidelity doesn't matter because we
cheat at similar rates so most women are
leaving their men because of financial
reasons and then these men are now
raised by women and then they try to
chase women but women don't know how to
call women so then these men are left
thinking okay my mom told me to be nice
and buy her flowers and then she looks
and then she he tries to do that for the
girl she's like look at his waist man
yeah
oh and and how are they supposed to feel
confident if they didn't have a man to
like raise them i agree with that
i agree with you i do agree with you as
you know when it comes to masculine
confidence it's best it comes from a man
be it your dad be your uncle whoever's
available to you and as a woman who has
had a strong relationship with her dad
it makes you a different type of woman
on the market you have a different level
of confidence you have realistic more
realistic
expectations towards men and you know
there's certain things that my dad
helped me understand as a woman i'm i'm
more forgiving than women in my age
group when it comes to not forgiving
that's the wrong word but
i have a better understanding of the
hardships that men face and i have a bit
more empathy towards their position do
you know what i mean but at the same
time having that understanding with a
a group of men who haven't had that
nurturing is still very difficult i got
a question for you then
would you date a simp
what's this i simply have the confidence
to approach me oh yeah
you're sympathetic of their position and
obviously you're being raised by your
father that's had an influence on you so
would you date a sim
being sympathetic
well
first of all in my opinion a simple is
not a man it's a it's a tiger ouch wow
no no she's not a man in my opinion like
if you don't have a diary
oh sorry
if you don't have certain attributes
then you're not on my radar so for
example i'm not a materialistic person i
don't look for someone with nice clothes
nice things blah blah but i do look for
a man who has logic direction knows how
so is your answer no yes no i wouldn't
they assume okay
right but like if you're sympathetic to
the plate of mine i didn't say
sympathetic i said empathy i'm pathetic
okay i'm pathetic why wouldn't you date
a simp yeah i wouldn't there's no
there's no compatibility there for me i
know that a man with logic provisions
knows what he's about would fit better
with me so
that's why
so um question do you guys think that
women date up or down
up up up i think depending on age
okay
so then then what do you say up i say
okay would you guys say up oh yeah
so how can we say women are the prize if
they date up and men date down that's a
good question that's a great question do
you know do you know that's an amazing
question i feel like the generation
we're in now uh-huh i feel like
everybody just has to date up because no
no everybody can't no so so
i'm just not
somewhat someone's reaching every
relationship someone likes the other
more exactly someone's reaching
someone's settling yeah okay personally
i genuinely feel like where we are in
this life here
everything is so difficult yeah
everything is getting worse and worse
it's not check your friend zone
wow good one it's not yeah
but i feel like a lot of my guy friends
we're compatible as friends and i'm not
and i don't want to lose that no no no
no you you're not attracted to them like
that or something you like the attention
no you like the attention yeah i'm
definitely attracted to some of my guy
friends i just wouldn't want to go there
would they want to go there with you
possibly
possibly however i just know that the
boundaries and i'd rather i treasure the
friendship i'm not trying to do that
yeah because more time if a relationship
ends up bad i've lost you as a friend
yeah and as that and if i value the
friendship i feel like but it can end up
good
what the relationship happens
that's the risk in it sounds quite
pessimistic
do you really see yourself having a lot
of male friends once you get married
does that really help no no yeah so
healthy that's not healthy that's not
all that might end anyways
so what's the point of having them
around no but i just feel like i'd
like in this day and age like you have i
feel like a lot of people are mad
so what do you what do you what do you
see as the problems in the dating market
the problems in the data market i feel
like um everything has become so what
can i get what can i get materialistic
and i feel like people aren't looking at
character anymore do you think that's
the man or the women i think it's both
you think it's the matter
also the women i feel like women
have become this which means that the
men don't even care anymore it's like if
you want them for maybe materialistic
things
quite a few women so it's kind of like
if that's all you look at me for then
all right cool i'll take you your sister
your auntie and then
could you explain that more what do you
mean so what i mean by that is there's a
lot of guys who let's say faithfulness
was something that let's say 10 years
ago was key right now in this generation
it's like nobody cares or quite a few
people don't care if the guy is faithful
not as long as he's looking after them
so you've got a lot of men who maybe
they were faithful growing up now it's
like i don't even need to be famous
because i can get the test
is that the fault of the men or the
women i'm saying it's the fault of the
woman yeah yeah okay i agree with you oh
yeah sorry i genuinely believe is the
fault of the woman because it's like if
you hand them a silver platter why would
they not take it
yeah and why do i need to be faithful um
um spiritual this this yeah if you're
not even required so why did you say
women are the prize then because i feel
like when you're growing up like i said
from a young age you're pretty sure that
i think when you get to a certain age
you need to understand you need to
understand the flower of your youth when
it's finished darling i understand it's
finished however i feel like um
naturally is your you're taught today up
because i just feel like
he just needs to be the head of the
household if that makes sense so the
head would mean he's up yeah so then he
would be the prize yeah but that's what
i'm saying my answer was when you get to
a certain age i feel like it flips
me okay i think let's say 25 and up 25
and 25
i think off the high school
no
i think i think men are always the prize
because because the women the women that
men want like
women 50 of women that hit 30 are single
and childless
so so the most i think you think men
understand they're the prize for young i
think i think the small percentage of
men do when they have when they have at
their doorstep
like from from the time they're from the
time they're
kid you know because it's only a very
small percentage of men that get that
and then you know the the women
like the women that
won't settle and i think they're just
going to die alone
no seriously because yeah and they won't
have kids and but fulfill their
biological imperative so you have to
compromise right yeah yeah i mean
something willing to though that's the
thing yeah but this is the thing like we
compromise where it always benefits us
and never benefits the man because when
we compromise it's like at 30.
and that's not what men want
questions
when you talk about the dating market do
all the women on the panel believe that
women are the problem in the with the
data market
they contribute they contribute 100 they
contribute because there's one can i
just say this yeah there's more women on
the market
in the days market and how i would put
it is everyone so a lot of women say
they're the prize but they don't act
like a prize so they're readily
available if you're available to 25 men
how are your prize you're readily
available i put it like this if you have
a rolex they don't advertise rolex you
know the value of it if you see a
ferrari they don't advertise that you
know the value of it if you're on
socials dating apps advertising yourself
with no clothes
you know trying to get male attention
are you really oppressed but what that
sounds like to me
that that sounds like a cognitive
dissonance to me so like you think of
one thing but you're not the other so
that still goes back to the fact that
women are potentially the problem in the
data market because of this delusion
that they they carry i'm the prize yeah
i deserve this and i deserve that yeah
really i'm not actually the prize
like how can you be a prize at all if
you're a virgin if you're not a virgin
if you're not so
much
no i'm saying like back in the 19 in the
1950s like like you were a hoe if you if
you slept with like two people i think
men nowadays would pray for two
and so it's like like
how are you a prize if you're not a
virgin and so you're well